Ngày hai miệng trên thống người, đại hồi đồng liên hình của quốc đã thông quanh nghĩ quét kêu của mình,
chấm rất lạnh cảm vận kinh tế, thương mạnh và tài trình đồng của quốc bà,
với một chăm sóm lắm phía thuật, bởi phía trống vào 12.7.
Đây là lần thứ 3 mi tư, nghĩ quét kêu của mình, nừng cảm vận của bà được thông qua,
kể từ năm 2019, thế hiện sự um hộp bên bì của cột đồng của tế, dành cho là ha bà nà.
Năm nay có vời nước bỏ phía trống của Mỹ, Hysurran, Hà Hè Tina, Hungerii,
bác mà SEDUNIA, Phà Waay và Uquena, có số này có hình đáng kể sau với năm ngoài,
hình hãy tư khi chỉ có hai nước là Mỹ và Yysurran Phà đối,
cho thấy Washington đã nỗ lực bật động ngoại giao mạnh mẽ hơn trong kỳ bỏ phía nóng này.
Một trong lập lộn được phía mi đưa ra là quốc bà đã cửa gần năm 2019,
tại Uquena, không tin này sau đó bị phía là hà bà nà bác bỏ.
Có thể thấy phần lớn các quốc gia vần dữ lập trường cùng hộ quốc bà và phản đối các biển pháp trường phạt đơn phương.
Pháp biểu chú của bỏ phía, ngoài trường của bà ông Bruno Roddy Gé chỉ trích lận thống bất là hình thức trường phạt tập thể
gây tổn hạn yên trọng tới đời sống người dân.
Ông khẳng định, của bà sẽ không có phục và tích tục kêu gọi đối thoại về Mỹ,
giữa trên sự mình đằng và tôn trọng trục quyền.
Firm Mỹ thì cho rằng việc nghĩ quên được thông qua là độc thải bao ché trong một trí đột thức bài.
Hì quên của lực hợp gốc không có giả trí giám bộ,
sông mang ý nghĩa chính trị to lớn khi cho thấy phần lớn có cuu gia,
vẫn yêu cầu Washington cần trấm rất lạnh cập vất kéo dài đã hư sau 5 năm qua,
vốn đất bàn hàng từ năm, người chỉ trăm sống 12 theo xác lạnh của tổn thống John Acc này đi.
Tuy nhiên, việc chính thức dựa mò lạnh cấm, vẫn phải giọc của hội Mỹ quyết định.
Huyến khả năng thay đổi trong hạn gần như bằng không.